[Music]
you get some kind of sick pleasure from
torturing other people I mean yeah okay
so Michelle and I did make up some lame
story we only did it because we wanted
you to treat us like human beings but
you know what I finally realized I don't
care if you like us is we don't like you
you're a bad person with an ugly heart
it helps drop the microphone you may
remember Mira Sorvino as Romi in the
1997 hit comedy Romy and Michele's high
school reunion the oscar-winning actress
is now guest starring in the new season
of startup on the streaming app Sony
crackle Sorvino plays Rebecca Stroud an
NSA agent who's trying to take down the
founders of a dark net site being used
for illegal activity in this clip from
the new season Stroud is accused of
freezing the assets of the company that
she's hoping to shut down you know as
well as anybody that this whole thing
has to hold up in federal court hmm Oh
sort of China but you know they could
remove the order and you'd still have
problems not with me of course more like
the DEA maybe you know with those
friends of yours down Little Haiti who
are still buying and selling arms and
narcotics through the same company for
which you currently serve as CEO I may
not have a back door but with your boys
I have a place to start looking she's
looking to Mira Sorvino was also a
prominent figure in the me2 movement in
times up and joins us at the table
Mira welcome we'll talk about that in
just a sec but I want to talk about your
character because I was reading the
writers and producers spent months
trying to come up with the right person
to play Rebecca Stroud and that when you
expressed interest they were thrilled
what drew you to her because you
described as a strange cat she's bizarre
she's a little lonely she has OCD she
has a southern accent you read it and
said I want to do her why well because
first of all the first two seasons of
startup are extraordinary it is such a
compelling amazing show so it was
already a tried and true seaworthy
vessel like when you watch it you are
just sucked in but I really enjoyed the
writing for her because she's bizarre
she's she's kind of broken and trying to
hide her broken edges without that much
as you see she doesn't really have an
easy time making eye contact with people
she eats the same meal every day from
the same fast-food in place and what did
that meal what is it it's it's a kind of
like a like a chicken burger and if the
bun isn't quite right and she has to
straighten the edges of the paper you
know the exhaustion she won't sleep in
her bed she sleeps on the couch in the
hotel and and it's too short for her and
that's the only place she'll sleep but
for her mother USA is the only family
she has and she will do anything that
she believes is in our country's self
interest including lie cheat still kill
but she thinks it's for a good reason
yeah and she's actually approaching Iraq
net the dark web internet service that
the characters provide on this show
asking them to open their doors so that
the NSA can look for people have sold
chemical weapons on their dark web and
they don't want to let me because they
have this you know that's the whole
point is the agnosticism no one gets to
know what you're doing no oversight no
hacking but I thought in her mind and
greater good of the quality it's
something very terrible and and as the
story goes along the characters have
this moral conundrum do we change our
philosophy to potentially prevent
something like another 9/11 yeah when
you have an OCD character like that do
you I mean did you go and eat the same
chicken for five chicken right yeah yeah
but you also can't eat a lot in the
scenes because if you take lots of bites
in one take and then you've got to do
them every single take until it's over
and then you're very full yeah many of
them many of them the plot line is
ripped from the headlines right yes well
you know it's all about Internet privacy
and hacking and how much does the
government or other people know about
you through your online habits and you
know this story promises you know that
the service promises you've complete
anonymity of course it draws criminals
to work on it but you know it's it's I
think it's very timely with hacking with
influencing with foreign agents
influencing us through Facebook etc you
know it's it's very timely mirror you
were one of the first people to come
forward to level charges against Harvey
Weinstein was it a difficult decision
for you to make
yes I'm sorry I'm laughing it was so
difficult that's why I'm laughing it was
very it was very hard I'm not trying to
be funny was it was it difficult yeah
yeah we're difficult it was one of the
hardest things I've ever done actually
because it it publicly something that
was intensely private and painful for me
and but talk about greater good though
what is some out of that what was going
but I could not have imagined that I
would be joined by a chorus of
like-minded people from around the world
who would raise their voice and say me
too and time's up and we want change and
you know that solidarity and that
discovering that so many people have
been victimized out there by sexual
misconduct abuse violence rape that we
are as Toronto Jean put it the other day
Toronto Burke she said that you know
we're a constituency we the survivors of
sexual assault and harassment and abuse
are a constituency and don't you think
it's affected politics today absolutely
and we demand better now because the
status quo is not working it's not okay
that statistically one out of three
women will become a victim we think it's
higher than that because most people
don't report and so now we're looking to
change laws and we're looking to vote
for candidates who have our best
interests at heart if you're not going
to perform in such a way that protects
and promotes our interests makes it a
safer more meritocratic equitable world
for everyone and protects us from sexual
violence and punishes perpetrators then
we don't want to vote for you and you've
been very active in California I was in
California yes yes where you got three
very strong laws passed this year I and
a group of other people worked very hard
to get this hashtag take the lead slate
of bills last and we're ending corporate
ability to fold in surreptitious legal
language in contracts that gets people
to sign away their rights to disparage
even if something criminal is done to
them and it's true and and they're
giving up the rights to claim it's going
to educate everyone working in the state
of California with five employees or
more it that's what you're doing in your
spare time
[Laughter]
yes thank you Mira I think what you've
started really by speaking out a year
later now thank you thank you well we're
only just getting started but it's it's
it's unstoppable at this point yeah nice
to have you here thank you I'm sorry you
know thank you and startup is available
to stream now on Sony crackle